how many refugees has Poland
taken zero every society every society
that has ever existed it existed because
it defended its culture and its people
so now we found this video it's an old
one but this is from old it's from 2018
this is British Channel 4 host Kathy
Newman and some of you may remember
Kathy Newman she was the one that sort
of put Jordan Peterson on the map when
she asked him a series of some of the
dumbest questions ever and he just
annihilated her here she is in
2018 talking to a a Polish Member of
Parliament his name is Dominic tar sinki
I hope I I said that right and she asks
him how many refugees has Poland taken
in because you may remember this is
during the Syria War 5 years ago
refugees rampaging through Europe taking
over Germany uh going through France
right like destroying Paris all this
stuff and Europe has that on their hands
now and they they fully regret it here
she is trying to guilt this member of
Polish par Parliament into how many
he'll take watch this how many how many
refugees has Poland
taken zero and you're proud of that if
you are asking me if you're if you are
asking me about Muslim uh Muslims
illegal immigration none not even one
will come to Poland not even one if it's
illegal we we took over 2 million
ukrainians who are working who are
peaceful in Poland we will not receive
even one Muslim because this is what we
promis but I ask not
illegal immigrants I asked about
refugees and Jean Jun the commission
President says that you're racist you
sound proud of the fact that you haven't
taken any
refugees of course because this is what
our people expecting from our government
that's number one this is why our
government was elected that this is why
Poland is so safe this is the the the
reason why we had not even uh one
terrorist attack look at the streets and
Poland and we can be called populists
nationalists racists I don't care I care
about my family and about my country I
want to what's the national drink of
Poland I want to have a drink with that
guy whatever it is I want the I will buy
the most expensive bottle of whatever
the national drink of Poland is you know
you can make all the jokes you want
about Poland and Polish people but
godamn they got it right right it's
vodka the I guess polish vodka I guess
that does make you always think of it as
Russian but yeah okay close enough um
he's he's right and the way she tries to
guilt him in it and you won't let in
one